health care experts say new federal
rules meant to make medical cost more
transparent instead created widespread
confusion this month the Centers for
Medicare and Medicaid Services began
requiring hospitals to post all their
prices online critics say the
information is difficult to understand
and the prices themselves are misleading
Anna Werner is taking a closer look at
those price lists Anna what did you find
well good morning you know anyone who's
ever received a hospital bill knows how
complicated they can be the new
government rules were supposed to
demystify hospital prices but three
weeks after it went into effect patient
advocates say people are now coming down
with a case of too much information I
was very worried that I was going to end
up not only in pain in my back but also
in my wallet
when christopher george injured his back
last year a doctor told him to get to
x-rays a friend told him about the price
checker service at st. Luke's University
Health Network in Pennsylvania where
George learned he could prepay for his
x-rays for about $100 each that's why I
went there
I knew what I was paying for the first
time matically but experiences like his
are rare a new government rule requiring
hospitals to post price lists was
designed to help patients figure out how
much they would be charged the master
price list went up earlier this month
but those spreadsheets often contain
more than ten thousand items with names
that resemble medical gobbledygook
we found something called an SC SP rplc
p IC c don't know what it is but it's
priced at about $8,500
Janie Pender runs a website called clear
health costs where consumers can look up
medical prices it's not comprehensible
to the average human being so you look
at this string of letters and numbers
what's that and no idea and I do this
for a living actually I'm confused by it
at one New York Hospital there are three
different listings for something called
ear priced at 48 to 110 thousand dollars
there are five more listings for other
ear procedures costing from 27,000 to
more than $150,000 or maybe you need a
procedure involving a stent
but would you be able to pick out the
one your doctors might use from this
Florida hospitals price list is it the
one listed at 5400 dollars or the one
that costs nearly nine times that what's
more Pinder says the prices aren't real
they're fanciful they're inflated
explain that so hospitals have a list
price that's very much like the
manufacturer's suggested retail price
for electronics or a list price for a
car very rarely is the hospital ever
paid that actual list price that's
because those list prices don't take
into account the huge discounts
negotiated by Medicare and private
insurers which are considered trade
secrets Pinder worries patients may be
misled about their actual out-of-pocket
costs you might find this wildly
inflated list price and decide that you
can't afford it and choose not to get
treatment
franciene Bo Tech a senior vice
president at st. Luke's believes
releasing price lists is a step in the
right direction but she also says
hospitals need to do a better job
helping patients understand that
information this is the direction health
care needs to go
if hospitals were doing what st. Luke's
is doing and offering transparency tools
patients truly would be able to do price
shopping and they would be able to
compare so there are no uniform naming
standards the other thing is we want to
compare prices between hospitals that
would be very hard to do they all call
it something different but it's not all
hopeless Jeanie Pender says there are a
few things you can do first
ask for the medical code that will help
you zero in on the actual item on the
price list ask if there are other
charges like surgical room rates or
medications or additional tests also you
can ask how much will it cost with
insurance and without ask about the cash
price you might save money and finally
if you can get everything in writing
there has to be transparency yes what in
what other part of our lives would we
buy something or get a service and not
know how much it costs the secrecy
allows for high costs it allows for
people to make profits at other peoples
expense
I know it's hard now but I hope this
transparency pushes change we have to
have knowledge about what stuff costs in
our health care
yeah it's the only way to get healthier
and to get better price any people don't
know what anything cause and then we
don't get the bill it's so darn
confusing I can't I can't I don't even
know what they're talking about yeah
it's not it doesn't even seem in English
to me and kudos to this administration's
FDA that's got God was mandating that
drug prices be advertised on commercials
as well so again once once again
promoting transparency more consumers I
was going to say we need to send your
report to somebody yeah it's really good
obviously you always do the best report
yeah no really hopefully this will help
some people with some tips
keep it coming thank you very good thank
you